hello and welcome to this video playing
zucchini 81 it is higher rated than me
okay
don't have that often right it's good
cool big Five's not a bad line d6 okay
that's not a very common way to play
this usually it's more of an e6 now it
goes it's 6 u6 is seen more more
frequently okay it's a very slowish
build up here for both sides actually
let's see how it plays with a 6 ok
and I think black is generally speaking
quite fine in these kind of positions
him so let's for some sort of decision
on the queenside
takes it I didn't expect that really I
thought I would be a little bit quicker
on the queenside
[Music]
great stuff to save a five is something
that I should play not easy
he wants to go Bishop f6 and put the
knight on d5 very interesting
but both captures make some sense em so
I do understand that he takes a bit of
time maybe just 96
96 I will attack both a5 and c3
yeah I'm not not very happy he plays as
well and I don't have a super clear idea
what you do
I intended rook e to D to be one but
have to be a term that doesn't really
help
hmm
and they're just a bad position may just
completely outplayed me just a bad
position of course that's not
objectively working in my attack but I
need to do something I can I cannot just
sit very strange not totally positive
what my mistake was sometimes you have a
pretty clear picture like okay this was
a bad decision and so on maybe the whole
set up with a five didn't quite work but
really a really uncertain
[Music]
yeah it will probably move the rook yeah
it doesn't really matter well okay look
some group have FC 8 or something I take
such okay
okay not totally unhappy that I am at
least at least looks like I could have a
threat once in a while okay
[Music]
and my king is also a quite open
yeah but maybe maybe I got got some
opportunity still okay would have liked
a more active move but that's what it is
okay
I completely overlooked that I cannot
take a four here shoot I wanted to take
a four but that doesn't work at all very
stupid yeah that's lost now no chance
really add to too little time I mean if
the position was objectively lost anyway
but if you ever have a little bit more
time and maybe can put up better
resistance there at least I think he
allowed a little something to just have
this feeling so what was wrong there I
mean here I don't think anything is
particularly wrong but maybe a five is
just not a good idea that pawn proved to
be exposed and ig4 is good
No age three
slowly but surely this is going downhill
it's already quite impossible to cover
to keep the pawn
I kind of feel like then maybe it was
something like when when I was able to
play h5 I felt maybe there is something
so we just took it
channels I didn't really have any
opportunity then yeah that that that was
wrong it seems so here I can take play
g6 so that was the opportunity a queen
g4 held a bit wrong but I didn't I
didn't have time to figure that out this
said now a5 is hanging in the h7 so
probably and here if I take know that
that cannot be an aside enough and then
just oh yeah okay I can actually do this
and then do the okay but I said yeah
it's got no way for with him you know
auntie em here I'm lost again
yeah they note no chance really I think
he did a good job there
yeah let's that opening line would be
five is annoying anyway what the engine
wants to go before yet that's the
weirdest move ever before Wow quite
remarkable
yeah probably with hindsight is this
plan doesn't look very promising
probably probably already a four it
doesn't really do much yeah anyway let's
go for a new game thanks a lot for
watching